[Music]
this is a family saga an extended family
relationship we go a long way back seven
or eight hundred million years back
[Music]
when multi-celled organisms first set
off from our single-celled ancestors on
the tree of life something interesting
happened we never left bacteria behind
we took them with us it was a
partnership from day zero they've been
living inside and on us for the entire
ride of the evolutionary tree we depend
upon them and they depend upon us this
wonderful cooperation where we both
benefit yet for most of our history we
didn't know they were there the first
evidence of microbes came in the late
1600s a Dutchman by the name of Van
Leeuwen hook he built the first
microscopes and described the first
microbes unbelievably great company of
living animals very pretty and
everything through water
he was pretty enthralled with these
microorganisms but wonder gave way to
fear as scientists discovered that many
of these tiny creatures had been making
us sick these are bad organisms truly
horrible pathogens that have clade human
existence which led us to believe that
eliminating them from our environment
from the water we drink and the food we
eat and from our bodies with Usher in a
new era of Public Health and it did
hygienic practices led to a spike in
human lifespan new antibiotics like
penicillin became wonder drugs saving
hundreds of millions of lives
it seemed the only good bacterium was a
dead bacterium but our ideas about germs
are changing we are beginning to
understand the very subtle roles that
they play in regulating our own health
they help us digest our food and fight
off dangerous invaders we don't know
whether a human would be able to live
any meaningful existence in the absence
of microbes inside every one of us is an
entire ecosystem a microbiome and
scientists began noticing something else
what led to this extension of human life
and reduced human suffering also may
have brought with it their own set of
problems many diseases are on the table
obesity heart disease chronic
inflammatory diseases things like
Crohn's disease diabetes many others all
on the rise our war on microbes may have
caused unintended collateral damage our
own health so getting back on good terms
with our longtime fellow travelers could
mean the rebirth of a beautiful
friendship at the end of today's program
you may have a very different
appreciation for the bugs in our
environment particularly bacteria which
is what we're talking about today
the first thing you need to understand
is that they vastly outnumber us each
one of us has about 30 trillion cells
human cells that are uniquely ours but
did you know that living in and on us
are 39 trillion bacteria okay without
further ado let's introduce our
participants our first participant is a
professor of medicine microbiology and
immunology at Stanford he's a pioneer in
the study of the human microbiome please
welcome David relman
our next participant is director of the
center of the microbiome innovation at
the University of California San Diego
he's the author of follow your gut and
dirt is good please welcome Rob Knight
our third participant is director of the
Wisconsin Institute for discovery at the
University of wisconsin-madison she was
a science advisor to President Barack
Obama
please welcome Jo Handelsman and
rounding out this distinguished panel is
professor of medicine and microbiology
at the New York University School of
Medicine and the author of missing
microbes we'll talk about that in a bit
please welcome Marty blazer David let's
start with you
so we evolved with microbes from the
very beginning but and we just told
everybody we all have our own little
world living in and on us but when do we
acquire that when do we get it so the
beginning is a little bit a little bit
uncertain we forget that our own
individual histories begin before birth
which means in this case that our own
fetal development was influenced by our
mother's microbes and her microbiome we
have probably a little bit of direct
encounter with some of those microbes or
parts of them before we're born but then
everything changes at the time of birth
and it's that passage through either the
the birth canal or out through the
abdominal wall that causes a sudden
change in our relationship with the
microbial world and Rob you you've had
you have some interesting thoughts about
this and a personal experience tell us a
little bit about your daughter correct
what happened there yeah sure so after
our daughter was born as you know when
you have kids things don't always go
according to plan and that was true for
us and we wound up having to have an
unplanned c-section for medical reasons
and straight after she was born we
catered here with the microbes that she
should know she would have had had she
came out the regular way so you you feel
that
that that exposure in the birth canal is
we we felt that strongly as parents now
the AAP recommends that you not do this
now that there's a lot of public
interest in it until the research has
done so it's not something you should do
from a clinical perspective right now of
course as a parent you're probably gonna
have to do a lot of things that are not
a hundred percent based on evidence
that's right
that's true I can tell you from
experience you know we saw in the in the
in the brief piece a whole bunch of
diseases that rolled by there seems to
be some suggestion that there's an
autoimmune component by that I mean that
the microbiome somehow interacts with
our immune system Marty can you talk
about that and just to set the stage
here what how might these interactions
be happening so mostly I talk about the
microbes in the gut and that's where a
big part of the immune system is in the
wall of the intestine and it's pretty
clear that there's interaction between
the microbes and the immune system and
vice versa and it's become more and more
clear that the microbiome is training
the immune system it's teaching the
immune system what are what are the good
bugs what are the bad bugs and if that
training is is off if it's misaligned
then there's a risk that the immune
system won't develop in the proper
manner so that's that's what we think
are driving some of the immunological
diseases to two-way street there yes
before we go any further we need to sort
of set the stage for how a lot of the
work in your area is done and it's done
with mice Joe can you explain a little
bit about how you use the mice in this
very unique way well the mice have been
particularly powerful because they can
be raised in a sterile environment so
they can be delivered by cesarean
section and kept sterile in a bubble and
then they can be inoculated with any
microbes you want and so it's the only
system we have where we can do a very
clean
microbiome or microbiome free gut and
then add back one organism a few
organisms or the entire microbiome from
the mouse or even another organism like
a human and and my studies are is this
primarily the way most of the work is
done well one of the powerful things in
the microbiome field is that it brings
together many kinds of data it's
epidemiological data on humans looking
at large populations and correlations
and then experiments on humans in
situations where we can actually do the
experiments with variables on humans and
then mice and other model systems play a
major role briefly back to to humans
though when we're first born we acquire
are the beginnings of our microbiome
when does that stabilize when do we say
you've got it this is you and and how
long does that take
wrong for the gut microbiome it's about
two to three years and then for other
side side the skin in the mouth it's a
lot faster so within a few months and
yeah I would just add agree the the vast
majority of what we see easily is
established by about two or three years
I think we all would agree though that
there have to be some other and really
important but more subtle features that
take a little bit longer well into later
childhood maybe even at the time of
adolescence and Beyond and even even
throughout age say the first three years
we have the most dramatic difference so
it's like your microbiome is going from
from seawater to to soil it's that
profound a change can hit two different
physical environments but then between
the time when you're three in the time
where you're 90 that's more like say the
difference between one patch of farmland
and another rather than being a
completely different kind of environment
so the change is still important but
it's subtle and this is the timeframe
when a lot of parents who have little
kids know that they get ear infections
and antibiotics are brought on board is
this a good thing a bad thing well I
mean it is what it is everything is a
trade-off in this particular case
antibiotics as you've heard and seen
have had an amazingly important role in
saving lives when they were you
for you know what turned out to be good
purposes but of course they have
collateral damage that they caused and
everything is is a trade off so when
they're not used for a good reason those
downsides are going to outweigh you have
you have an opinion on this I do so so
that the the point is as we know
antibiotics are miraculous you know when
they're used appropriately but they are
overused tremendously the CDC estimated
30 percent of the antibiotics are
overused I think the actual number is
higher in Sweden they're only using 40
percent of the antibiotics that we do so
it suggests that maybe 60 percent of the
antibiotics aren't necessary and in the
US this tremendous variation between
doctors between regions parts of the
country that aren't explained by
differences in disease there there
differences in practice and in culture
some people and some doctors want to use
antibiotics more others don't there
doesn't seem to be much difference in
outcome so let's talk a little bit about
the human microbiome project a lot of
people are familiar with the little
petri dishes that's what we think about
when we talk about studying bacteria but
there's a whole new way to study
bacteria Jo can you sort of walk us
through what that is and how that
intersects human microbiome project well
about 30 years ago scientists began to
realize that we've been missing a vast
amount of knowledge about the microbiome
every microbiome not just in humans but
in soil and in oceans and on trees and
the reason that we've been missing that
information is a lot of microbes some
vast majority won't grow in culture
so those petri dishes that we all
associate with microbiology are only one
little sliver of the story of
microbiology and so the the effort
became to study microbes without
necessarily culturing them and to
circumvent culturing them we started
extracting DNA and so that's the the
major way that we describe microbiomes
today and most of the work we'll talk
about here is based on DNA analysis so
it's not the old-fashioned petri dish
that's gone some of it's not gone at all
some of it it still is
when we want to study a particular
organism and it can be cultured that's
one of the most powerful tools we have
but if we want to look at the entire
community including the half or in the
case of other environments besides the
human system as many as 99 percent that
can't be cultured then we need to go to
the DNA mess and Rob you've done a lot
of work with this tell us about it and
let's take a look at some of what you've
done if you can describe it sure so what
what you're seeing here is is my
daughter's microbiome developing over
the over the first two and a half years
of life and what you can see is she's
starting off with these different
regions the gut and brown the mouth and
blue the the skin and sorry the map and
green the skin and blue and she's moving
more and more towards the healthy adult
stage as defined by about 15,000 healthy
people in the American gut project which
is our citizen science initiative where
essentially anyone can get their
microbiome sequenced and so what's
exciting about this is even to a
six-year-old you can explain how she's
starting off in one place on this map
she's moving to another place and what
the regions are that are defined by
health and disease
so the different explain again the
different colors represent the different
colors the microbiomes and different
parts of the body each dot is the whole
microbiome so potentially a thousand
microbial species from one or one
individual and we placed two dots on
this map close together if they're more
similar in terms of the evolution of the
microbes that they have in them we place
them further a part of them that won't
dissimilar in terms of that evolution
how unique is each person's microbiome
every every person's microbiome every
time you sample it is unique so if you
if you sample yourself today three
different times and you sample yourself
tomorrow three different times we can
tell those apart from each other so it's
all of this it's all a matter of scale
it's about how different are you from
yourself how different are you from
other people and which of those
differences are large and which is small
and it's important to remember that you
don't have just one microbiome the
microbiome of your mouth your gut your
skin they're all completely different
from one another
in fact Rob's gut is a lot more similar
to my gut than my gut is to my mouth
for example even within the human mouth
there's diversity is that that correct
absolutely a very striking demonstration
by Julie Segway at the NIH about the
different habitats of the human skin and
how they're as different as rob was
saying as as grasslands are from forests
are to deserts let's talk about what
we've been doing in the last what 40 50
how long is the 70 years 70 years that's
what that's when antibiotics first came
on about 70 years ago and this is an
area of intense interest to you Marty in
fact he wrote a book that's been
compared to Silent Spring and its
importance in terms of understanding
exactly the impact we're having on our
own ecology if you will called missing
microbes tell us a little bit about that
book your thesis and and sort of what
you think about the future yeah so Medea
begins with many of the things that
we've discussed before the idea that the
microbes that we have in the human body
are ancient that we've inherited them
from our ancestors that they're formed
the structure of our microbiome occurs
early in life that they have benefits to
us they're doing all kinds of good
things and and now there's more and more
evidence that our microbiome is changing
that we have lost diversity that we have
lost important ancestral microbes and
I've hypothesized that this has
consequence and and there's more and
more evidence that the consequences are
related to the diseases that are now
becoming epidemic since World War two
we've had rises in asthma in obesity and
diabetes and juvenile diabetes and
inflammatory bowel disease and there is
an increasing body of evidence for all
of these that the change in the
microbiome is playing some role in the
story you and I were talking beforehand
and
you you likened it to other sort of
human intervention impacts like climate
change yeah so climate change is how
humans are affecting the macro ecology
through modernization through all the
things we did when Henry Ford or Benz
developed the internal combustion engine
they didn't anticipate that the every
time you turn the ignition that the ice
cap in Greenland is going to melt a
little but we think that that's true and
and in a sense I think that that's
what's happening in our human bodies
every time we take in antibiotic
perhaps a few organisms become extinct
and exactly yeah that's kind of change
change in our micro ecology is parallel
in our macro ecology you also said you
think what's happening to our microbiome
is happening much much faster
yeah well it's we're seventy years into
the antibiotic year and antibiotics are
not the only factor c-section there are
many other factors involved but maybe
it's it's the most important and so it's
a difficult problem antibiotics
miraculous they save lives but we're
overusing them so we have to we have to
dial it back and we have to understand
what we're doing and then how we can
restore what we've lost
dirts good write your book tell us why
dirts good it's good because exposures
have a lot of natural microbes out in
the environment whether it's from dirt
or whether it's from animals and farms
or healthy healthy water healthy soil
and so forth has a surprising number of
beneficial effects and can give give the
microbial diversity that we need to
reduce the register the frequency of
some of these conditions although it's
an open question how much we can restore
like I think a much more direct analogy
with antibiotics as DDT where it's save
millions of lives and yes you have a
hugely deleterious effect on the
ecosystem and then afterwards just
introducing a few rats and pigeons isn't
really gonna cut it for improving
biodiversity again right so
understanding what we're changing and
what we need to do to restore it is a
really key scientific to
the moment in the meantime if you're a
parent and the pacifier hits the
sidewalk do you boil it do you call in
the hazmat team yeah well it depends a
bit where the sidewalk is like if you if
you think there's a lot of ledge
maybe you shouldn't you know maybe you
should wash laughs but it's more a more
chemical than a microbiological thing
that you should worry about so if the
drops on a hospital floor you probably
want to wash that off right about it
that's if it's our time are if you don't
have any reason to believe that this
anything bad they're probably the
positive effect outweighs negative any
any opinions here on the six second rule
for some reason NIH hasn't funded a lot
of research I'm at no big problem let's
talk about some of the specific diseases
that we we've been alluding to the first
is is asthma asthma is a major public
health issue if you're in New York City
there are certain neighborhoods in New
York City that are truly plagued with
asthma overall 8% of Americans have
asthma but we've looked at these sort of
ecological studies and the story is
actually very kind of stark when you
look at very particular communities two
of the communities in a recent article
in the New England Journal of Medicine
looked at the Amish and the Hutterites
why those communities and what did we
learn from them yes so this was weak
from Jack Gilbert and Derek Hough on
Regius and a number of other of they
collaborators and what's amazing is that
the Amish and the Hutterites both live
what we would consider relatively
traditional lifestyles very farm based
but they have completely different rates
of asthma where the Amish have
essentially no asthma and the Hutterites
have a lot and what's different is that
the Amish will take their kids on the
farms to interact with the animals
whereas the Hutterites have a very have
a very tight distinction between farm
life and home life and they make sure
that they change their clothes they
don't take their kids out on the farm
and so on and the exposure to particular
kinds of microbes including some kinds
of lactobacillus seems to be really
important for that difference in health
between the two communities the Amish
were six times
unless likely Desmond allergies and the
Hutterites and the Hutterites have
asthma rates that are consistent with
the rest of the country does this does
this go towards what they call the
hygiene hypothesis for the development
of diseases can anyone that's right so
the first iteration of the hygiene
hypothesis was the idea that exposure to
childhood pathogens was good and there
hasn't been a lot of evidence in favor
of that what we're thinking now is much
more along the lines of its exposure to
this diverse array of beneficial
microbes from the environment looks good
but by trying to trying too hard to keep
yourself away from the pathogens you may
also be walling yourself off from this
beneficial microdata did you want to add
to that no I think I mean a lot of this
says marty was saying it's just a
function of what we have been doing both
to ourselves and to our environment it's
a function in part of the built
environment now we have segregated
ourselves from the environments we used
to be born and raised in and it's
striking that kids traditionally have
liked to eat soil and a lot of animals
eat soil in fact when they're sick some
animals self-medicate with soil so it
seems like there's some natural process
of ingesting soil and maybe we're
learning why that that was an impulse
for so many kids in some ways when you
look at those kids and what they do and
what we all do it's really also about
continuing to sample the our environment
in order to find those missing microbes
right that that that can fill in the the
niches that and habitats that have been
emptied and so in some ways that natural
behavior is a really a very adaptive one
I know you guys are working on some
additional information about this yeah
we're working on a new study with Erika
and Bavaria where where you have you can
go down a street and you'll have houses
that have cows where they bring the cow
into the barn versus houses that don't
have cows and even on that level one
house to the next down the street if you
have a cow you're much less likely to
have asthma but if you don't have a cab
and now obviously in New York
recommending that everything aren't
getting
particularly helpful so so this is an
ongoing going study that okay alright so
we so that's asthma but I think even
more interesting than asthma is obesity
and you know we all know that obesity is
an epidemic in this country this is not
news but Marty you have looked at we've
overlapped some information and what
you're talking about in terms of the
obesity epidemic and some of the so
there are many things to say but I don't
want to take up the whole time but you
know one of the most important
observations these are data from the CDC
and the the darker the color the more
the higher the percentage of obesity so
you can see the difference between 1989
and 1999 and 2010 so this is only 21
years something very important it's
happened it's happened all over the
country and about 2012 we we made the
connection and I think it's in the next
slide that if you look at that if you
look at the obesity map and the regional
variation in antibiotic use there's a
lot of similarity there's a lot of
overlap so that's it that's kind of
interesting it doesn't prove anything
because it's observational but 70 years
ago farmers found that if they gave
antibiotics to their farm animals it
would change their growth they would
grow bigger they'd grow faster it
changed their metabolism and they found
that the younger they gave the
antibiotics the more profound the effect
so we thought that maybe that's one of
the things that's feeling this and we
began to do experiments in mice like as
with others in which we could give
antibiotics to mice as the only variable
and if that increased their obesity Jo
you've done work on that can you take us
through what these Mouse experiments
where yeah this isn't my own work but
other people have done obesity
experiments where they transfer the
microbes from obese humans into mice and
they see the mice gain weight quite
dramatically I think this was one of the
turning points in the microbiome
research field because we began to see
cause and effect as am already said the
those maps show you great
epidemiological similarities and
correlations but this was a direct
effect by transferring microbes it's
it's amazing I mean how how could this
work is anyone working on what is the
mechanism the elixir the genetic turn
that happens here what we and others are
working on it's not genetic its
environmental it's because the obesity
epidemic is too fast to be a genetic
problem it's it's not taking multiple
generations it's happening in years and
again it goes back to the early years of
life when the microbiome is forming it's
educating our immune system it's
educating metabolism it's educating the
liver and the fat cells on how how big
to be and how much how much energy to
store and how much to save and it's very
it's it's very conserved because the
farmers found that it works in cows it
also works in chickens and there's a big
big swath in vertebrate evolution is
there is there any knowledge about
exactly what the microbes are doing that
we there there are many things that are
going on at the same time it's it's
changing how the microbes use energy
it's also changing how the microbes are
signaling human cells at this critical
early time of development and that's
also a strong correlation between the
inflammatory response and many chronic
diseases and so the bacteria are in
direct contact with our gut and they can
incite an immune response or
inflammatory response and there's some
evidence that reducing that inflammatory
response with food or other additives to
the diet including microbes may be one
of the ways we could treat obesity I
would just add a note of you might view
as slight caution but actually I think
it's incredibly exciting the idea that
that these communities like any of the
communities are amazingly adaptable so
they will recognize conditions those
members and
and interacting parts of the community
that are favored will flourish and the
others not so essentially these
communities remodel themselves under
whatever condition they are presented in
this way they become almost a a
reinforcing factor for whatever the host
or human disease or health state might
be and I think in part that may be why
the transfer of a gut community that's
now adapted to a state of obesity will
bring with it the metabolism and the and
the and the and the biology that it took
for them to adapt they bring it to that
new host but it's just it's a piece of
the story and it's a caution in the
sense that the microbial community is
not the whole story it could be a
reflection of as well as a driver of or
a reinforcer of whatever the host
problem might be yep yeah and especially
with human obesity there's a lot of
complex moving parts there even even
even my slow one one thing we haven't
heard yet about is behavior and for
example and the toll-like receptor v
knockout mice that we studied without
recourse and briefly what was amazing
there is that you have a genetic change
in the mouse that causes the causes of
microbial change but you can transmit
from one house to another and transmit
obesity what was going on there was it
was almost all behavioral so the altered
microbes made the mice eat more that's
why the became obese you can make them
lean again by just cutting off their
food supply to what a normal Mouse would
eat and and so these connections between
the gut and the brain are really
exciting even in the context of things
we might think of is more physical like
obesity Marty you said it's not genetic
right that it that this phenomenon that
we're seeing is not genetic and yet you
have also said that certain conditions
like inflammatory bowel disease may
actually be
transmissible to the next generation so
how does that work if it's not genetic
well you know when we classically save
genetics we're talking about our our
human genes passed from generation to
generation but of course we're also
passing our microbial genes from
generation to generation when when we're
born it's it's not quite as precise as
the humans but there's still a lot of
inheritance of the microbial genes and
we've we've done experiments to look at
this particular question we you've done
experiments in mice and this should what
are we looking at here yeah so so this
we're looking at the colon of two mice
on the left side are we'll call that the
normal and the right is the perturb so
the experiment we did here is that we
took poop essentially from mice that
were either normal or had received
antibiotics so we had a perturbed poop
in a normal poop and we gave that to
germ-free mice mice that had no flora
who happened to be pregnant and who also
were immunodeficient they were aisle ten
deficient mice these are mice that
spontaneously developed colitis and so
now we gave the poop to them to the moms
either the normal the perturbed then we
asked would the mom transfer the
microbes to their to her pups she did we
followed the pups till they were
middle-aged and then when we sacrificed
them we looked at their colon and what
we found is that the mice whose mothers
got the perturbed poop they had much
worse inflammation that's that's the
panel on the right had much worse
inflammation in their colon than the
than the other so there was a huge
difference and the point here is that
those pups never saw an antibiotic their
mother never saw an antibiotic all they
saw was a perturbed poop so this was
evidence that the signal that the the
disease signal is being transferred by
the microbiome
it also is evidence that the inheritance
is also involving microbiome involving
microbial genes not host genes right so
not host genes microbial genome what are
the implications of something like this
well one one one implication is that
many of the diseases that we think are
genetic it may be more than human
genetics for example inflammatory bowel
disease if you take all of the genetic
low-side that have been found to be
associated with inflammatory bowel
disease that explains 10 percent of the
risk the other 90% was unexplained I
think this is part of it it also has
kind of profound social implications
because it means that we can pass our
experience on to our children you know
Lamarque was sort of debunked a long
time ago the concept that we acquire
traits during our lifetime and then pass
them on in other words if you lift
weights a lot your kids will get big
muscles exactly right and and you know
we we don't believe that that sounds
silly but on the other hand if we're
passing on our microbes and they're a
product of our existence and our during
our lifetime and not just our own genes
then it really has almost a and I I
think almost anti-democratic quality to
it that you know it says that the old
adage of pulling ourselves up by our
bootstraps and creating our own lives
and every life is a new life and has the
fresh start with all the opportunities
just simply isn't true we are literally
inheriting our parents experience wow
this brings us this is a good point to
talk about Adebayor antibiotic
resistance and before we before we get
to that we want to talk about the the
bad boy of an type of resistance bugs
one of the baddest boys and that is C
difficile which causes untold miserable
outcomes in many many people and the CDC
has termed this a very urgent situation
but there is a very wholesome potential
treatment for this and we're going to
talk about it in this video that was
senior ologist for a chronic pelvic name
they were just prescribing me antibiotic
after antibiotic the antibiotics cleared
up the infection causing his pain but
then Ryan began to get different
symptoms I finally found out that I had
to see death c-diff or C difficile is an
opportunistic microbe that often
afflicts those whose micro biomes have
been compromised by antibiotics it's
notoriously difficult to treat and makes
day-to-day life miserable see death can
be life-threatening people can die of
this none of the medications help with
my symptoms has been really draining
having this disease for so long I have a
disease I know is due to biome
disruption let's fix the Bible easy to
say challenging to do the treatment it's
called a fecal transplant detective
service fmt fecal microbiota
transplantation it's exactly what it
sounds like someone with a healthy
microbiome has donated his stool to be
placed in Ryan's colon we drive our
camera to the top of the colon squeeze
in some vile sport it in with a syringe
that's exactly how elegant it were not
elegant inside of a simple there are
trillions of bacteria that when
transplanted actually out-compete a seed
of bacteria and that repopulate you soon
after the procedure Brian was free from
C death
[Music]
how does that work
did you is this more than you bargained
for is everybody okay well I mean the
the good news is that it's it's been
almost a miracle for example like this
patient here and many others
it's remarkable in fact that it that it
works at least in this circumstance and
the idea is that in the wake of this
very inflammatory destructive infection
caused by c difficile and its toxins the
the habitat is damaged and yet in some
ways unstable and and receptive for a
new community to replace what is now
sort of the ravaged remains of what
might be there and in that particular
setting the provision of a new community
it's it's really restoration ecology
allows the the habitats may now be
filled by a community type that really
was destined in some ways to be in that
environment when the inflammation has
subsided so it's a very particular
circumstance and i think a very
important lesson about what we ought to
be working towards not necessarily you
know poop as is but next generation well
restoration well the good news is you
can get the poop in a pill you can get
poop anywhere actually it looks like I
found that to be true here in New York
so true it's so true but so well I mean
it should we be should we all be seeking
these this type of treatment I mean can
I reverse obesity this way what what is
what are the limits of this right now
well the first thing to say is is the
the c difficile infection of very
specific diseases we know what causes it
it's acute and onset the treatment is is
really has now become the standard of
care because it's so good and it's the
proof of principle but that doesn't mean
that other conditions conditions that
have been going on for decades
conditions that we don't know the cause
of you know will be affected those are
the kinds of questions that have to be
addressed in clinical trials trials were
just like we've made enormous progress
in treatment of many cancers the
treatment of HIV that's all come from
clinical trials where they've compared
one medication to another one approach
to the other and gradually we've ramped
up our approach to these diseases and
that's what has to be done in the
microbiome field - they are trying it
with certain diseases aren't they what
what is the status of that that work
that lots of ongoing trials now for
everything from Crohn's disease
ulcerative colitis to obesity and any of
these conditions that we've been talking
about there are trials underway I think
my own view is that it's going to be a
bit tougher and and less likely to work
easily for the reason that Marty
suggested we don't know the the
instigating cause or something that's
easy enough to knock down temporarily
the way we can knock down c.difficile
temporarily in order to open up that
niche space for the new community a lot
of these diseases as like the health are
associated with intense resilience the
system whether it be harmful or
beneficial is really stuck in a deep
valley that's hard to dislodge and we're
going to have to figure out I think
ancillary approaches along with the the
restoration community in order to
dislodge
a harmful community state and replace it
with a beneficial one I know one of the
things about the fecal transplant
studies that is kind of frustrating is
that they worked so well with c-diff
that patients don't want to stay in the
studies they just get better or they go
out of the hospital after 48 hours and
they're done and so we don't have a good
enough understanding of why it works
even in the most extreme case that we we
can't really transfer that knowledge to
the all the other much more complicated
conditions that you're talking about
it's important to point out that c-diff
is a disease that is acquired by up by
physicians who give patients lots and
lots of antibiotic kill their natural
microbiome and the c-diff takes over I
mean so they're very different than some
of these chronic disease could happen
even with one course of antibiotics
it can happen even with it doesn't have
to be lots of but but it's a but it's an
insult that we know that happens in that
unlike Parkinson's and some of the other
diseases those diseases that are going
on for years or decades right that's the
problem but you know one of the problems
is that all these diseases are
heterogeneous there may be many
different subsets in there and if if for
example the fecal transplant worked for
10% of the people right now we can't
really tell whose that 10% and and we
need much better tools to understand and
for example back in the old days breast
cancer was considered one disease and
now we know that there at least three
major pathways if we tried to treat
everybody with one treatment we would be
under treating some women and over
treating others in kind of a way that's
where we are on the fecal transplant for
many of these other conditions and
is a large proportion of patients that
respond even to their own fecal
transplant being transplanted back and
that doesn't really make sense given the
mechanism we think it's acting by so we
don't even understand it with that
disease early days yes the the
heterogeneity is even not just with the
disease and disease states and
individuals in host but also in the
therapies so what is you know one
person's fecal miracle is another
person's fecal dud and because they're
just not well characterized what we need
to be working towards is a much more
precise blend of organisms and nutrients
for those organisms in a particular host
matched in the right way that it that it
makes sense yeah and the the American
Gastroenterological Association has has
set up a new National fecal transplant
registry to try to attract all the some
Gabbar to get the evidence that we need
to figure out when it's going to work
what formulation you should use whose
poop is right for you all that kind of
stuff
what's okay let's let's pass the call in
and up to the brain you know for a long
time we thought that these systems had
nothing to do with each other they
didn't communicate in any way but we're
beginning to understand that there is a
real connection between the brain and
the gut and one of those connections is
through neurotransmitters things that we
if you familiar with them at all you
know do you think of them only in terms
of the brain but that's that's not the
case there is a there's way more of a
connection there than we we've thought
about in the past Joe can you well it
you know we knew things that we ignore
it and one one of the statistics that's
so interesting is that serotonin is one
of the most important hormones for brain
activity and for happiness and we know
we've known for a long time that 90
percent of the serotonin receptors are
in the gut well what are they doing
there yeah we should have been asking
this a long time ago because that
discovery alone should hint that it's
not just about the brain and so for a
long time we've thought of the gut as
the second brain and that probably is a
pretty accurate description and what
they're interacting with we don't know
but we can imagine they're interacting
with microbes and the chemical products
of microbes that may mimic
neurotransmitters or it may produce
serotonin itself or we don't know what
else we know that depression is a
tremendous problem worldwide it's I
think the World Health Organization
listed as the number one health threat
in the world
how can there is some working on how we
can use this understanding about the
microbiome and its effect on on
depression to the to help patients again
like many of the things we've talked
about it's a little bit too soon for
treatment but there's clear evidence
that the the microbiome in depressed
people is different from the microbiome
on
in not depressed people and so we need
to be asking whether we can do fecal
transplants whether we can change diet
whether we can take probiotics or other
in chemicals that would change the
microbiome in important ways there was a
fascinating mouse experiment where they
took the microbiome from depressed
people and introduced it into sterile
mice germ-free mice and they found that
the mice from that received the
depressed people microbiome became
depressed
want to hear about depressed mice no a
mouse is depressed
we had a great picture of a depressed
mice yeah what's going to come up there
we are
[Applause]
poor little guy will come back to the to
that to that fella in one second but we
know we learn about the blood-brain
barrier in medical school that nothing
gets past the blood-brain barrier it's a
very very tight system but that's not
necessarily true where the gut is
concerned they're actually connected in
a way how how does that work well there
are a lot of connections they're just
very precise it's not an easy flow one
of the easiest connections is electronic
so the flow of neural signals from the
gut to the brains through the vagus
nerve is an enormous route for
information to flow so you could imagine
that's an image of the vagus nerve you
could imagine microbes stimulating the
vagus nerve and the gut and that having
an effect on the brain
another way that microbes could be
affecting the brain is we know that the
composition of the microbiome in terms
of which organisms are there changes the
composition of chemicals in the blood
and blood certainly can deliver
chemicals to the brain blood certainly
crosses that barrier so there's no
question that there are ways for
information to flow from the gut to the
brain and in the figure that was just up
with the vagus nerve we are hardwired
with signals going down from the brain
and coming up from the gut or is that is
that something that is being studied in
humans could it work in humans we talked
a little bit about it but that work is
just beginning and of course we have to
remember mice aren't humans and mouse
depression is not identical to human
depression but some of the symptoms are
remarkably similar so one of the tests
they use is the swim test and it turns
out that mice will swim for quite a
while to try to survive but if they're
depressed they quit they just sort of
flop over and will give up and so
there's the the helplessness syndrome
which is one of the symptoms of human
depression as well they also become less
adventuresome and so if you put a mouse
on a little island it will dip its toe
in the water like a cat
but if it's depressed it will just sit
there and hold back so there are all
these symptoms that have corollaries but
of course we're human we're making a lot
of inferences there and imagining what
the mouse is feeling so of course all of
this needs to be transferred to humans
and they called the study transferring
the Blues which is yes yeah again you
know the incredibly promising if it can
be used to to design a useful
intervention the the complications of
course are that that depressed people
eat differently their activities are
different the degrees and ways in which
they interact with other humans are
different they take medications and so
all of those things we know can
independently affect a micro biome that
microbiome in turn may now turn into a
reflection of all of those factors given
to a mouse may not be so surprising to
induce changes that we read as similar
but again the actual causation and
multiple contributions of many factors
make this much more complicated much
harder to solve unfortunately then that
might the mice yeah so David is is
emphasizing a very important note of
caution I think we're all here because
we're enthusiasts about the microbiome
we recognize that it is a scientific
frontier just like many scientific
ranches that's going to bear a lot of
fruit one day but maybe not tomorrow
because it's going to take time to
translate and to understand all these
new findings and to convert them into
new approaches to health and treatment
it's not it's not coming tomorrow
except for c-diff right sometimes it
takes only one study to take a gigantic
step forward I thought that the brain
science that that people are doing now
with the microbiome would take forever
to begin to sort out what's really going
on in those mouse brains and then just
last month the paper came out that
showed anatomical changes in the
amygdala which is the part of the brain
that controls
and and and depression to some degree
and if you changed the microbiome in a
mouse you change the structure of the
amygdala now that's starting to get to a
structural level and I think ultimately
it will be a biochemical level where we
can really dissect it so sometimes it
just takes a very innovative study to
take that giant next step and get down
to the mechanism of what's girly x but
would you agree that there are hints
that there is a strong strong
association between what's happening the
in the gut and and behavior Rob I think
you've done some work in PTSD or you're
familiar with this yeah well well again
again mice's mostly in in mouse models
but with Chris Larry a boulder and a
number of others we we were able to show
that if you expose mice to the right
kinds of soil bacteria an organism
called Mycobacterium vaccaei then you
can put it on a social stress condition
so basically you either put it in with a
huge dominant male Mouse that would beat
it up or you just let it watch up
through the earth watch that through
glass which also upsets them right and
so normally they'll huddle in the corner
of the cage they won't eat their hair
falls out but if you inoculate them with
these soil bacteria they're very
resilient against that stress and we
also did another study looking at
looking at children with PTSD where
there was some microbiome differences
between those with and without PTSD but
again we don't have causality and that
we just have association so so server so
the concept but you can modify the
mouse's behavior in response to social
stress by by adding a microbe that's
very exciting
but it takes a long time to translate
that to something that you could do in
humans
and you've even looked at mice with
autism is this correct and we haven't
but Sarkis mazmanian
Caltech has has done that and so what
we're seeing here that's the marble
bearing test so one of the hallmarks of
autism is compulsive behavior and that's
a mouse that can't help burying marbles
and the reason the reason is that likes
to bury marbles to correct so you'll say
the number of marbles that buries in a
fixed amount of
just make sure as the measure of how
much is this like a repetitive behavior
exactly like you like the mouth patient
of OCD interesting yeah and so so what
what happens is when you when you
injects the pregnant female mice with
with double-stranded RNA so you simulate
a viral attack and then the pups do that
they have communications deficits they
have cognitive deficits and they have
problems with their GI tract all of
which resemble human autism and so watch
what Sarkis showed was that this
molecule code for ethyl phenol sulfate
that's over produced in the microbiomes
of those of those pups and if you inject
a normal pup with it it'll do many of
the same things you can also use a
natural microbe out of the human gut as
a probiotic to reverse some of those
effects so again this is all preclinical
there there was another consortium of
three groups in Arizona that did a
really exciting clinical trial that was
published a little over a year ago with
a small number of kids doing fecal
transplantation for autism and so they
saw some benefits both in GI dysfunction
and also in cognitive function in those
children but it's still very early days
right it's a small open label trial and
before you believe that it's going to be
the next thing it likes seed if they can
be addressed with fecal transplant you
really want to see a lot more research
but it's very encouraging has anyone
looked at populations that have not used
intensive antibiotics the way we have in
developed countries and what their micro
biomes are like compared to an Americans
microbiome yeah so so Rob and I have
been involved in several studies that
have looked at that very question and
the people living out in the jungles in
the bush who have not had much
modernization their micro biomes are
much richer than ours they're much more
diverse and that these are people who
live in Africa and South America and New
Guinea they're genetically different
they're on all different diets but what
they share in common is that they have
very rich microbiota and the people who
live in Italy Australia u.s. different
continents different ethnicity
etc Japan but we share modernization and
industrialization our microbiota are
less rich does that have an implication
on their health are they are they in
terms of the chronic diseases we've
talked about today asthma obesity some
of the those comparisons are different
or difficult because we are different
from the people living in the jungles in
many different ways but in general they
have less asthma they have less obesity
but that it's hard to prove things from
that but what we can say is that they
have a much richer microbiota and it
suggests that theirs is more typical is
more similar to our ancestral microbiota
and that we have lost diversity so if I
understand this correctly you're saying
that it's possible we cannot recapture
that diversity that we most likely
started with like some of the yeah I I
don't think we want to say that it we
certainly don't want to believe that we
need first of course to understand what
parts of that ancestral diversity if you
will are important to us today and in
some ways of course you don't want the
HUD says microbiome in order to be able
to survive in New York today to who the
hodza was the one of the ancestral
hunter-gatherer populations that would
not be well-suited to modern day life
but in turn we ought to be thinking
about what elements of it should we
attempt to restore what functional
aspects can we restore can we restore
and should we restore in order to
improve you know long term outcomes and
avoid some of the calamities of modern
life if that's Rob and I are involved in
a new foundation that
that my wife Maria Gloria Dominguez is
establishing to create a microbiome
vault similar to the seed vault that is
in in Norway to preserve all the seeds
of humankind you guys familiar with the
seed vault was that a yes yes they do
they yeah so the same idea is is to is
to archive those ancestral microbiota
now before they're lost so that at least
we have the resource so that if there
will be if restoration will be feasible
we will have the materials for the
restoration we don't know yet whether it
will be feasible or how I'm optimistic
but it may it may take some time to
figure out what are the rules what are
the ground rules is is is the
restoration of my children going to be
the same as the restoration for your
children I think for us maybe we're it's
a little light it's a little late it's
not so much the crop trust is the crab
trust if you will we really need to
preserve this material now while we have
the opportunity right well we've spent a
lot of time sort of talking about the
ways that we've hurt ourselves and our
own microbiome over the last decades if
you will with antibiotics and other
things let's try to end on a positive
note let's talk about ways we can
enhance or improve or change things
going forward how can we keep our
microbiome happy what should we be doing
Rob you talked about getting outside
tell us a little bit about that give us
some advice how can we be moving forward
for ourselves and our kids and maybe
maybe turn things around a little bit
here
sure well the the most important thing
you can do for your gut microbiome based
on what we see in the in the American
gut project is eating a wide range of
different plants so that seems to matter
a lot more than if you sit down to a
huge plate of kale or if you sometimes
eat meat but that diversity and in plant
sources seems to be really important
so so okay also when it comes to
particular foods what types of foods
should we be eating well so at a general
level you should avoid sweets and salty
snacks but I think you knew that already
one of the things that's coming out in
the microbiome us of this amazing
individual variability that explains why
different people respond differently to
changes in diet so the science isn't
quite there yet to give personalized
recommendations but it's getting pretty
close and in the context of individual
research studies that's working pretty
well now don't we know that insoluble
fiber for example increases butyrate
producing bacteria and butyrate is a
pretty important part of God health
absolutely and that's really good for
most people but if you have IBD it's
it's a significant problem and eating
fiber is really bad so that's that's why
it's always challenging to give
generalized recommendations that work
for everyone but but there was one
Israelis there was one Israeli study in
particular from Aaron CL Adair and Alan
F at the basement Institute a couple of
years ago where when they looked at
their population they found for a fairly
sizable fraction of people it was
actually better for their blood sugar to
eat ice cream than it was to eat rice
and they never expected that ration when
you find that out you might wonder you
know a certificate or a test I can do to
find out if I'm in the ice cream or the
rice category and the answer is yes but
so far it only really works in Israel if
you recently Israeli diet but then the
more interesting question was you know
suppose I'm in the category people who
should eat rice and I want to be in the
category of people who should ice who
should eat ice cream can I change my
microbiome to get there and that's the
kind of thing we don't know yes but it's
plausible based on what we can do in
mice will we one day be able to match
the things that we need to be doing to
our microbiome sort of the way we might
other things in other words use
information about our microbiome to
inform what what medicines might work
best for us is that that's very
plausible and again in the context of
research studies figuring out if a
particular drug whether it's a
painkiller whether it's a hot drug
whether it's a checkpoint inhibitor for
cancer will work on us based on the
microbiome that works really nicely
which label it's not yet ready for
clinical use because it has to get
through a FDA approval and so on but
that's probably coming pretty soon
that's a huge frontier because with
every medicine that we use we know that
this tremendous variation in how well it
works what's the level of toxicity and
there's more and more evidence that your
microbiome is one of the controlling
factors so if we could understand that
we could make drugs work better and less
toxic more effective or choose the right
drug for the right person as well
yeah and billions of dollars have been
spent looking for those answers in the
human genome but they're probably not
nearly as much there as they are in the
microbiome and the other thing is you
can't change your human genome right to
change it from being a non-response or a
responder but you may be able to change
a microbiome in just the same way that
that variable response to drugs is so
individualized and potentially related
to the microbiome so is individual
response to environmental chemicals all
right heavy metals in the environment
look at lead look at arsenic
there are huge populations at risk and
yet within a population of identical
exposure there's a lot of variability in
outcome and that's where I think we
could have a huge impact in public
health on both predicting who is more or
less likely to suffer the ill effects of
let's say lead because there are genes
in our gut microbiome that managed these
metals they've seen them for eons and if
we can predict that that would be great
and if we could do something about it
it'd be even better
you mentioned response to different
medications and there is some work at
antidepressants is that correct that
there's my lab is actually starting that
work with some collaborators at
Wisconsin so we don't have anything to
tell you what's the goal there though
they know that it's for people who are
depressed it might take several trials
to find a drug that works for them
there's no one pill that works for
everybody all the time
no and
fact the efficacy of antidepressants for
any given antidepressant working in any
given person is the lowest of any drug
group so it's about twenty percent
response rate so typically people have
to go through four or five drugs to find
one that works and that's a very long
and painful and depressing process yeah
and so if we could upfront decide just
by a microbiome sample which person is
likely to respond to which drug it's a
very quick and and I think short term
use of microbiome data because we don't
even have to understand the mechanism if
and we hope to but if we find such a
connection it would just be a predictor
that could save physicians and patients
a lot of a lot of times we already know
for example that tylenol response is
microbiome driven so there are
differences in the human population
that's been known for years and there
are several other drugs coming along
that look like their efficacy is driven
or in some cases toxicity is driven by
the microbiome likewise anti-cancer
drugs that the big recent wave and the
use of checkpoint inhibitors now is
clearly related to the presence of
certain kinds of microbes in your gut
that that either make them more or less
effective it's incredible we must
discuss probiotics we've only got three
minutes forty seconds left
yes or no Marty the future is great for
probiotics we're all thinking that there
will be probiotics that people can use
most of the materials out there for sale
and the health food store grocery store
pharmacy very variable almost completely
untested so caution on the probiotic
thing it's it's hot right now it's real
millions of people take it every day yep
astonishingly little data astonishing
little debt okay there are some really
good studies that show effects of of
probiotics some of the lactobacilli in
particular lactobacillus Reuter i which
seems to be throughout the mammalian
world which suggests that maybe there's
some coevolution of
mammals with that that bug that seems to
have reproducible effects and people
there was meat by reproducible effects I
did it had it well in one case it had
effects on the immune system and it
reduced inflammation and then there's
another study that shows a lactobacillus
that reduces depression that was just
one study from England that hasn't been
reproduced so I think there are several
things coming along that we will have
data okay just don't how to save your
money for the moment what about you Rob
yes they just like with drugs there are
there studies the particular probiotics
work for particular clinical indications
but that doesn't mean that you should
just take a whole lot of probiotics all
the time even if you're not sick and
even Eddie any more than you should take
a whole lot of drugs all the time even
even when you're not sick okay there's
enough to say that the future is bright
the present is a little bit murky David
Mills at UC Davis did a study and showed
that about half of the things that he
could buy in a health food store when
sequenced in his lab were not even the
organism that the label said they were
and we know that this not just the
species but the strain matters so I
think we're just we're working with
really imperfect material right and we
can't know yet the probiotic
manufacturing industry is the Wild West
the Wild West okay caveat emptor buyer
beware okay Marty I just wanted to end
you have a particular vision for what
the future might look like when we've
understood the role of the microbiome in
our own health you say that particularly
pediatricians are gonna have a very
different way to examine patients what's
that going to look like well certainly
we're gonna live happily ever after okay
but beyond that I think III envision
that the doctor of the future isn't
examined babies and they're going to
examine babies diapers and they're gonna
analyze those that those diapers with
then the knowledge that is being created
in laboratories all over the world and
tried to use that information to
optimize health
and if there are particular microbes
that are missing in that baby that every
baby should have I believe that the
doctors of the future will be giving
those microbes back and that there may
be specific microbes that that baby is
missing that they need that that will
become part of the medical care of the
future not tomorrow maybe 20 years from
now I'm not sure stay tuned right we'll
get back to you on that right I want to
thank the panel here today David Robb
Joe Marty thank you so much for this
incredible discussion
[Applause]
you
[Music]